tout n'est pas donc perdu dans ce pays
Michel Sardou remontera sur scène Sardou
le retour Sardou le mot 323 chansons
Sardou qui parle de cette fille aux yeux
clairs Sardou qui évoque cette maladie
dont le plus douloureux et quand on en
guérit jeune Australienne numéro un
mondial on la voit en photo vainqueur de
trois tournois du Grand Chelem qui a
créé la stupéfaction en annonçant sa
retraite en mars dernier voilà et la
retraite à 25 ans est-ce que c'est pas
un truc qu'on devrait aller défendre sur
des barricades
à 25 ans Seigneur point
bien sûr des lignes de métro fermées en
nombre et un trafic très perturbé sur le
RER la perspective d'un Jeudi Noir dans
les transports en commun assemble-t-il
décourager nombre de Franciliens de les
emprunter conseillons
sur cette ligne automatique est donc
ouverte certains craignaient une très
forte affluence il n'en est rien ce
matin mais en ce qui concerne les
correspondances c'est souvent beaucoup
plus compliqué donc pour moi c'est
plutôt SOS fainéant en détresse voilà
comment je pourrais qualifier cette
graine et ça commence vraiment à embêter
tout le monde moi j'ai mis je ne sais
pas combien de temps à trouver mon gs7
je trouvais pas j'ai dû prendre
taxi G7
club à faire ça me coûte encore plus
cher donc au niveau pouvoir d'achat
c'est pas top et imaginons les gens qui
doivent vraiment se déplacer donc en
fait il paralyse les mauvaises personnes
pour être sûr d'arriver à l'heure
beaucoup sont donc remontés à la surface
à la recherche d'un vélo encore
fallait-il trouver de la place pour
pédaler pas forcément la fin des ennuis
pour certains
le matin parce qu'en fait il y a même
des bouchons à vélo maintenant donc
c'est pas c'est pas si pratique que ça
si on pouvait oublier un peu les gilets
jaunes parce que moi je ne peux plus les
encadrer je ne peux même pas même la
couleur jaune maintenant je peux plus la
supporter j'ai peur que ça leur donne
l'idée de venir nous pourrir la vie à
nouveau donc si on pouvait ne pas trop
parler d'eux ça m'arrange pas en rythme
sur la musique du rappeur Florida c'est
une vidéo qui a fait 16 millions de vues
c'est quelques jours derniers il serait
concilier avec la démocratie
représentative
non mais les gilets jaunes avaient quand
même un discours très
antipolitique anti-parlementaire et là
c'est assez pardon mais assez cocasse de
voir Jérôme Rodriguez à la sorbée
nationale on apprend également que le
short sera interdit à l'Assemblée alors
ça c'est bien dommage pour les députés
parce que excusez-moi mais le short
c'est quand même le top
[Applaudissements]
exactement et c'est très dangereux et
malgré les risques de chez scrapo c'est
devenu un truc très recherché certains
sont même prêts à payer jusqu'à 7700 €.
là
haute mer en pleine partie de pêche au
large de la Nouvelle-Zélande c'est
marrant ont eu la surprise de voir
débarquer sur l'avant de leur bateau un
requin non pas marteau mais Mako ce
squale réputé pour sauter jusqu'à 6
mètres hors de l'eau a pu être filmé par
l'un des marins selon les pêcheurs cet
animal de 2 mètres 50 est resté deux
minutes sur le bateau avant de repartir
dans l'océan ces gens disaient mais nous
on préfère mille fois aller en
Angleterre ou en Allemagne que venir en
France d'un mois comme comme français
ben moi ça me fait souffrir pardon je
suis désolé même si j'ai parfaitement
conscience
qui veut avoir les migrants à un camp de
migrants dans son quartier qui est-ce
que Thomas on va parler franchement
est-ce que tu as envie de les avoir chez
toi
on va on va déjà regarder les
indicateurs
d'abord parce que on peut élever aussi
appelé le débat je sais pas tu as fait
des études quand même tu peux tu t'es
pas obligé de parler comme une
poissonnière
parce que vous êtes pas confronté à
cette immigration mais non je ne suis
pas non mais bien sûr je disais non vous
n'êtes jamais vous n'habitez pas porte
de la chapelle mais vous n'y êtes pas
c'est un peu facile pour vous attendez
vous êtes dans les beaux quartiers et
moi aussi d'ailleurs
on se croirait chez quotidien là oui si
tu veux alors
la population totale c'est 03 %
[Rires]
qui retourne en Afrique
du public non mais le spectateur
ah merde ah ça y est je viens de faire
un truc à base bah oui je suis en train
de retourner le voilà c'est intelligent
d'accord ok
[Rires]
non il y a un malaise
merci beaucoup c'est très très bien joué